Wonderful.
Mark Schwartz, so great to have you
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you so much.
My pleasure.
Happy to be here.
This is gonna be so much fun.
I'm so excited for the next 20 minutes
because we're gonna talk about
how you were on the board of directors
of Starbucks and you helped them raise
their first institutional funding.
We're gonna talk about firing
without adverse consequences,
In class, you teach at Claremont
if I'm not mistaken.
So, you did Harvard MBA.
You went to Claremont before.
And I'm really, really excited.
Let's start off back in the day,
we're at Starbucks
and you're getting involved.
So, the process of helping Starbucks
raise capital was not an easy one
in many perspectives.
It was difficult internally
at my investment banking firm
Donaldson, Lufkin, Jenrette.
I remember going to banking review
for approval of the deal.
Taking a red eye.
And there was this one person
on the committee
who couldn't understand
why anybody would pay
a dollar for a cup of coffee.
And he looked at the first page
of the book and used the F bomb word maybe,
I don't know, 30 times.
"Who's gonna pay an f-ing dollar
for an f-ing cup of coffee"
Yada yada yada.
And I turned to my colleague and said,
"Who's gonna tell him it's a dollar fifty?"
And basically, I managed to
walk into Tony James' office,
who's the vice chair of Blackstone,
and told him that,
"Look, Tony,
you're on the board of Costco
and Jeff Rottman
is mentoring Howard Schultz.
It's 6:30 in the morning out there.
Call him and tell him we're
not gonna do the deal."
And Tony said,
"Okay, just get the deal done."
And I said,
"What about banking review?"
And he said, "You just had it."
And then the other issue was
the company had just opened
its first store in Chicago,
which was out of the Pacific Northwest.
And it wasn't going well.
And the key learning and lesson
from opening new stores in a new territory
is just like the expression,
"All politics is local"
It can be said that all retail is local.
And so the consumer behavior
in Seattle wasn't necessarily the same
as the consumer behavior in Chicago.
People didn't stop in the winter
in Chicago
even though 400,000 people
walked in front of the store.
And ultimately
they closed the store.
Wow.
We did get the funding done.
We actually raised 30% more
than we were going out for.
Probably could have done
even more than that.
We did it at a slight discount
to our offer price,
but the good news is we raised more capital
than we needed and we got the deal done.
And I think the most important issue
in raising capital at any stage
is getting the capital.
It doesn't matter.
It's pretty binary,
either you got the money
or you didn't.
And so we were able to get
the money and move forward.
And then I got to serve on the board,
which was a fascinating experience because
I was a young investment banker
and I learned
more than I contributed.
Mark, unbelievable.
Did realize, did you have the slightest understanding
that Starbucks is going to become
what it is today?
I knew that Howard Schultz
was a unique executive
and entrepreneur,
even though a lot of people
couldn't see that.
I think he had a certain charisma
and a passion that was rare.
So, I think eventually
it would be successful.
You know they, it wasn't always great success,
but I think he was an
unbelievable student.
And one ... people on his team,
and was just fearless
about going after something.
Amazing. Amazing.
Okay. Mark, So, I want you
to take me a little bit
throughout your different ...
because you also co-founded
the largest US-Hispanic supermarket.
And you are now teaching class about
how to fire
without adverse consequences.
So, tell me a little bit about your life,
about what drives you and your passion.
And then let's move on to firing
because it sounds like something
that every CEO needs to really hone.
And it's a lesson that
I'm gonna have to learn
either the hard way or the easy way.
I'm gonna choose the easy way
through this talk.
So, it was through the Starbucks connection
that I got introduced to somebody
who became my partner
in founding Bodega Latina,
the Hispanic supermarket company.
Jamie Shannon introduced me to Al Lujan
and we worked kind of as a side gig on this.
And then when it was getting
very difficult to have
fundraising meetings
only in the evenings and on weekends
sneaking a few in
I decided to take the big plunge.
I was definitely inspired
by Howard Schultz in my own
entrepreneurial journey.
I think the training I got
in investment banking was excellent,
but there was something about
being an entrepreneur that was liberating,
and that was a great experience
that I think I really wanted to have.
Right. So, you didn't just have
an entrepreneurial experience,
but you've co-founded,
you co-founded
the largest US-Hispanic Supermarket.
What size did it get to
just to -
Over three billion in revenue.
Easy. Just three billion.
Just another
entrepreneurial experience.
But Mark, most importantly,
let's jump into this firing
without adverse consequences.
What is that about?
Why are you teaching a class
in entrepreneurial finance about
firing without consequences?
So at my alma mater,
Claremont McKenna College,
I serve on the board of
The Center for Innovation
and Entrepreneurship.
And often at meetings,
students would come in and pitch us
for funding for their business
or their app, as I would call it.
And to sort of defuse -
By the way, when did it transition
from business to app?
How long ago?
In most cases, it never did in my mind.
I got an app and I want money.
Yup.
Okay, do you have a business?
So, oftentimes what I would do,
these were students and they're
19, 20, 21 years old
and they were good
at creating an app,
but I don't know that they had any idea
or concept of managing a business
and building a team, etc.
So I would use this question
as a way of sort of
really kind of separating
wheat from the chaff.
I'd say, "Tell me about the last two
people that you fired and how that went."
And I get a deer in the headlights response.
Oh, don't worry.
You probably took that course in college.
And again,
there isn't that course
so you couldn't have taken it.
And I did this a couple of times.
And then I think the tipping point for me was
a company that I had invested in
and a founder that I was mentoring,
sent me an e-mail saying,
on a Friday afternoon, saying,
"I'm thinking of firing my co-founder.
Do you have any tips?"
And I thought that was such
a broad expansive question.
It's like I want to be an entrepreneur.
Do you have any ideas of a business
that I could be the founder of?
I like the analogy. Yeah
And so what I did was
I put together kind of a resource
based upon my own education.
So I, too, did not take that course.
I went to the school of hard knocks
and learned it the hard way
by being on the other end
of a bunch of wrongful
termination lawsuits.
So, I put together this lecture
on how to fire
without adverse consequences.
And then ultimately I repurposed it
for a school of nonprofit management.
And I wrote a case study
based upon a nonprofit organization
that I was involved with,
and the firing of the executive director
and changed the names
so it would be fictitious.
Right.
And a couple of the key takeaways
from that.
First of all,
again, all politics is local.
All employment law is state specific.
So, you have to know the laws
in the state in which you are operating
and the state in which you have nexus -
Which today is kind of almost impossible
as you have employees scattered
all across the US,
let alone all across the world.
And we're just transitioning
to accelerate to even more of that.
Right?
Right. But ultimately
where the company is headquartered
and is more than likely to be
the domicile of where the state law applies,
regardless of where the employee
is physically located.
Right.
But it is a legal process
and the law changes.
So, you need to have
the expertise of an employment lawyer.
And the second thing is
when you go into
the termination agreement process,
I say you need to do at least two things.
One, you should be scripted.
So that it very apparent that you
are reading from a script.
And there isn't any deviation.
And second of all, you want to have
a witness on your side
so it becomes a two on one.
Okay. I wanna dive deeper
into these two things.
I'm picking up my computer
because it's making some funky noises.
So I'm taking care of in the meantime.
But you're saying two on one.
I mean, I'm thinking about myself
coming in to a termination room
where I'm about to be terminated
and I have two people
reading out a script to me.
That doesn't feel very personal.
It doesn't feel like they
care about me too much.
It's actually designed to minimize
the litigation fallout.
Okay.
And as the employer,
that's what you're concern.
What am I doing in order to prevent
the wrongful termination lawsuit?
Right.
And all of the
issues that you're talking about
are dealt with prior to this.
You know, I look at firing
as a mutual liberation.
Some employee is not living up
to their highest and best potential
in this organization.
You are doing them a career favor
by parting ways
because you don't want them
to be a sub-optimal
or sub-performer
when they could very well be
much better in a different environment,
in a different job,
depending upon the circumstances.
And then you don't want to have
the sort of nasty,
periodic performance reviews that
basically don't do anything but cast
a pall of doubt on employees.
So, in some ways termination
is the human way to end suffering
on both parts -
I mean it sounds very very rational
when you put it that way,
but is it also
the responsible of the CEO
or whoever is managing the termination
to make that clear?
Because right now
especially as we saw in covid,
a lot of large corporations,
the way that they dealt
with their termination,
and that's what's in the back of my mind,
there was a whole variety
on the whole spectrum of how
you deal with termination.
A lot of them were accused
of wrongful termination.
A lot of them were praised
for their termination tactics.
So, what's your take on that?
So, every situation is different
and the law is different
depending upon the circumstances.
Most of what you're talking about
during covid-19 would likely fall under
what's called a reduction in force.
Okay.
Some of it was a furlough where
they were still getting benefits,
but they weren't getting any salary.
Right.
You know, I'm talking about
a individual who's not performing
and you've taken a lot of necessary steps
to try and improve that
performance, performance improvement plan.
And it's very clear
it's just not working.
You know, my experience is,
when it comes to firing or terminating,
you want to fire fast and hire slow.
Most companies flip it around.
They take forever to hire someone
and the firing
I'm sorry.
They're very quick to hire -
They hire everybody and they fire slowly.
Right. Right.
And then they're slow to fire.
You want that,
what I say is,
When do you know it's time
to terminate someone?
30 days before you got the first notion
in your mind.
It's sort of like, in
in my experience,
it doesn't get better.
It drags on.
It gets worse.
Wait a minute. How many of these
have you been involved with?
If you could just estimate
over your career how many firing dilemmas,
situations were you somewhat of a part in?
Oh, probably dozens
where I directly went in and handled
the termination and so on.
So, you've seen it all.
You've seen the good, the bad, the ugly.
Okay. Wow.
Is there a specific occurrence that
sort of like light switch
went up went off and said, "Wow."
Like there are lessons to be learned
about firing when you are
giving it so much weight?
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, if you've been through
a wrongful termination lawsuit
and see how much time and expense
can be taken to patch together
a termination that didn't work out,
you kind of realize that this is an ugly side of business
and you want to avoid this
as much as possible.
I'm sure. I'm sure.
Mark, I'm going into my own journey now.
My own entrepreneurial journey.
I could only wish for myself
that I get half of the incredible
experiences that you've had.
And we didn't even mention that right now
you're still sitting on
quite a few boards, right?
On incredible companies.
One of them is 129 year old
pharmaceutical company.
A pharmaceutical retailer in Seattle,
Bartell Drugs. Yes.
It's older than Nordstrom's
and General Electric.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
So, you're still very, very active,
but I want to use the last minute to get
one or two key pieces of advice
that you would have for me
as I'm entering my entrepreneurial journey.
So, I would talk about
finance and raising capital.
And I think one of the most
important lessons I learned the hard way
from my own entrepreneurial journey
and what I try to impart to entrepreneurs
as either an investor or a mentor or adviser
is make sure you raise enough capital.
And so in my Hispanic supermarket company,
we didn't raise enough capital
in our first round of financing.
And I thought
we were going to be able to
secure some equipment leasing or
equipment financing for the store,
and we weren't a credit worthy tenant
or borrower to be able to do that.
And we required the personal guarantees
of all of the investors.
Had we raised enough capital so we could have
just purchased it outright
and not had to finance it,
we would have been
in much better shape.
And as a result of that experience,
myself and my co-founder,
lost some of our equity
when we sold the business
and we had our liquidity event.
That equity was worth
a substantial amount.
And it just reinforced the issue,
if we had raised more money,
we might have had some of that equity.
Very very fascinating.
Mark, right before we leave,
I wanna thank you again for all this inspiration.
And I look forward
to maintaining this relationship
and continuing to get advice from you
definitely when I start my own company.
I have it sounds like I have an infinite to learn.
But before we leave,
I need three words from you
that best describe you.
I'm a finance and operationally oriented
entrepreneur and board member.
And what?
And board member.
Wonderful.
Mark, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
Have a great day and shabbat shalom.
Shabbat shalom.
And thank you, Michael, very much.
It was a pleasure and good luck to you
and your entrepreneurial journey.
Thank you.
And we didn't even get a chance to talk about
how we're both at J-Ventures
and how much fun I've been having there
and your amazing contributions to the fund.
So, thank you for that, too.
Of course.
And say hello to our friend Odet.
I definitely will. Thank you.
Take care, Mark.
Take care. Bye now.
Bye bye.